c'est sur le site historique du lazaret
à la grande chaloupe que s'est déroulée
la journée européenne des langues
l'occasion pour le club de solidarité du
lycée agricole de saint paul de
présenter la concrétisation de leurs
projets à vos sens nous avons réussi à
aboutir à l'édition d'un livre adapté
aux enfants malvoyants
c'est à dire gros caractères qui se
détachent sur un fond munie des
personnages les héros isolés sur un fond
simple détour et et avec un petit effet
une tactique c'était un effort physique
de façon à ce que l'enfant malvoyants
puisse repérer où il doit concentrer son
attention puisque seuls les héros porter
cet effet tapissier décoller le pays
d'en bas la mer un texte qui évoque la
solitude mais aussi l'aspiration à la
dignité et à l'autonomie de petit héros
handicapées il a inspiré les jeunes du
club de solidarité qui l'ont adapté sous
forme de spectacles de marionnaud
cette journée a été l'occasion de
présenter l'adaptation du conte sous
forme de cd audio
un projet né du désir d'accompagner les
enfants déficients visuels vers une
écoute puis une lecture autonome mais
aussi de rendre le message véhiculé par
ce conte accessible à tous le cd du
livre a d'abord été proposé en français
puis en créole réunionnais pour ensuite
être décliné en plusieurs langues
régionales
on s'est dit qu'il fallait aussi
s'ouvrir aux oreilles une oreille aux
siens ont parfois une culture viennent
d'une culture régionale donc on la dcri
née dans les langues des les côtes de
france de métropole
et puis on s'est dit que ça serait quand
même bien s'intéresser aux autres créole
quand les crieurs de rue st indien mais
aussi des antilles et aussi de guyane ça
nous semble un formidable outil
potentiel en langue et culture régionale
et puis c'était l'anniversaire du
peuplement de la réunion dont on s'est
dit quand même
n'étaient pas satisfaits d'avoir
seulement donner la parole certaines
communautés
donc on l'a déclinée dans les clous dans
les landes des communautés que parler et
certaines communautés à leur arrivée
parfois ces langues ne sont plus guère
pratiqué par hommage à ses ancêtres et
aussi des langues modernes qui n'était
pas non plus pratiqué au même comme le
chinois est qui
ce cd audio a été auto édité par le club
solidarité du lycée agricole de saint
paul
deux jeunes impliqués et fier d'avoir
contribué à ce projet solidaire dont moi
j'ai fait la transcription en faire le
réunionnais
ce projet là m'a permis d'avoir une
ouverture s'ouvrir aller vers les autres
sous verre aussi vers le monde connaître
aussi bien la maladie etc mais le point
indispensable de ce projet c'est c'est
notamment c'est la solidarité
la journée européenne des langues a été
animée par divers ateliers sur le
langage et s'est achevé sur un concert
de ta vie cycle